welcome everyone
has everyone had a good conference so
far
so what I'd like you to do this is my
favorite Conference of all time I love
coming to Oslo I love NDC and I think
that the organizers deserve a big round
of applause cheer as much as you can
awesome
I truly do love all the conversations we
have in the hallways the discussions we
have around programming languages and
everything that we can learn from each
other so for the next hour we're going
to be talking about what's new in
c-sharp how this programming language
has changed and the language features
that have been introduced in c-sharp
which changed the way that we try to
express ourselves
and I do bet that if I get invited back
next year this talk will be titled what
used to be C sharp and what's now F
sharp
and you'll soon see why there's quite a
lot of influences in c-sharp coming from
functional programming languages
I'm Phillip beckberg I've been here
quite a few times I've got some courses
on plural side covering mostly c-sharp
so if you like my stuff check that out
as well and I'm always available for
questions send me a DM on Twitter talk
to me about programming languages or
just life in general I'm always
available
with that being said we're going to hear
we're here to talk about c-sharp and how
this programming language that we all
hopefully love
we want to know how this has changed now
there are quite some features in c-sharp
that have over the years changed how we
express ourselves fundamentally changed
the way that we architect our
applications
language features such as generics being
able to use lambdas being able to use
Link asynchronous programming using
async and a weight but not every version
of c-sharp introduces those kind of
groundbreaking features
but there are some changes from c-sharp
eight and onwards that do change this as
well and the reason that the dust or
it's still possible to add things to a
programming language I mean c-sharp has
been around for a very long time
the reason they were still able to add
language features is because it's now
open source everyone can participate and
you know add their comments to
programming language designs talk about
what do we want in c-sharp essay
programming language
we can participate in these discussions
or if you really like programming
languages you can even participate in
sending pull requests
so they've got the the compilers as an
open source project
and what I think is most important about
this is that I can go ahead and look at
the ideas Behind These features what's
the reasoning behind adding more things
in c-sharp right I think that's valuable
maybe it's just me that like to spend
time on GitHub reading about language
stuff but I do really like c-sharp and
with that being said C sharp 7
introduced some groundbreaking features
but at the time it wasn't really
something that you'd use
because they waited until c-sharp 8 to
fully make use of these language
features so I promise that we're going
to talk about c-sharp 8 9 10 and
possibly even what's coming in C sharp
11.
but before that there's two language
features from c-sharp 7 that I think are
important to understand before we go on
to talk about c-sharp 8. now
C sharp 7 is the first and only version
of the language where they did Point
releases I believe this is a proof of
concept that since the compilers are
open source they can release this
independently of visual studio and
release it as an updated nuget package
for example they did some changes in
c-sharp 7.1 7.2 7.3 just to prove a
point
but what they did introduce is something
called tuples or tuples depending on how
you like to pronounce them we're talking
about the same thing
but this has always been available
in.net this here is tuples in older
versions of c-sharp or in.net rather
but this here becomes a little bit
tricky to work with this container of
multiple different values it's quite
useless if you have to access item one
item two item three it would be better
if this was like in every other
programming language a first class
citizen
so what they did was that they
introduced this as a first-class citizen
we can now Define a group of elements
that belong together very much like a
class or a struct but it's more
condensed like it's created in place
instead of having to create a new file
I guess it's all about saving characters
right this can be used to return
multiple values from a method or accept
a parameter with multiple values
but why would you use this in C sharp
seven there are some use cases but where
it's really powerful is when we in
produce pattern matching and that's one
of the last things we talk about in this
talk so just keep this with you for now
topples is a groundbreaking feature in
the language that has been around for
quite some time in other places
together with this in c-sharp 7 they
also introduced a way to look at objects
differently
imagine that we add this very magical
named method called deconstruct don't
confuse this with a deconstructor or a
destroyer or a whatever it's called
another programming languages it doesn't
have anything to do with the construct
or Garbage Collection or anything like
that what this here is doing is that it
introduces a way for me to pull an
object apart
and treat it and assign it to different
variables a little bit differently from
what you were used to if I add this to
any type that has these properties that
I can set on my now out parameters I'll
be able to
to do this I can say take my instance of
a person for example and now initialize
two local variables using that method
quite great but still it's a feature
that alone like this here I probably
wouldn't find a lot of use case for this
where again this becomes useful is with
pattern matching
and we'll see that soon as well
so why this is interesting is because
they've introduced features in older
versions of c-sharp if they're going to
keep doing this adding small features
that might not make sense now but in a
few versions from now it's going to make
a lot of sense because you have the
entire picture
now
this here comes together like tuples and
deconstructions you can take a tuple
that you have in in the right hand side
here and you can deconstruct that or do
a tuple assignment and this will now
belong in a completely different type of
representation
it's useful
but where it's even more useful is if I
can can take an instance of that class
and say hey how about you deconstruct
this and assign this to two new local
variables
it's pretty powerful and it's all built
on top this concept called a deconstruct
you can have as many of these as
possible and if you're using record
types which is also something we're
going to look at all of these are
auto-generated
so C sharp seven that's years ago right
this is a feature that's been around for
five plus years
but it was only until c-sharp eight and
in the year after that or a couple of
years after that that this became useful
so in C sharp eight it feels like with
the eighth iteration of the language
shouldn't C sharp be completed well if
it was I probably wouldn't be standing
here talking about all the next versions
but there's still a lot of things that
we can get into the language which will
help us express ourselves a little bit
differently
saving characters making our code more
easier to read and ultimately making it
easier to maintain
we've covered quite a few of these here
but C sharp 8 introduces something known
as read-only members it introduces a
concept of default interface methods or
default interface implementations
depending on when you read the
documentation last
kind of tend to change names a little
bit
then they introduce some pattern
matching enhancements so c-sharp 7
actually introduced a first version of
pattern matching I haven't covered that
yet because again that's something that
wasn't really useful until c-sharp 8. it
has a few more really great features
we're not going to be able to cover all
of these but then another groundbreaking
feature that we're also going to spend
some time talking about it's nullable
reference types a new way of looking at
reference types in our applications
being able to spot when something could
blow up before it actually does sounds
magical and hopefully we'll all go away
from this and use that in our
applications
asynchronous streams a way for us to
work with the synchronous data secret
disposables ranges and indices no
equalizing assignments there's quite a
lot inside c-sharp 8.
right to use this we'd have to use a
very specific version of.net and this is
where it becomes a little bit confusing
because we won't have time to talk about
the difference between dot net
framework.net core the new.net and
everything that's going on with the
naming and all of that
let's just say use the latest version
of.net and you'll be fine you can use
all of the latest and greatest of
c-sharp as well
but as you see here
c-sharp relates to the version of a
specific runtime and that's because
c-sharp 8 for example was the first
language version in a very long time but
depended on runtime changes so they had
to ship this as a part of the the
process of shipping the the runtime
and.net as well and the same goes for
some new features in c-sharp and Dot net
as well
you probably want to jump on the latest
LTS version the long-term support
version I've been talking about c-sharp
8 and some of these older versions for a
few years but it's only now that this is
first getting traction because now
people are starting to use.net 6 which
is going to be supported for quite some
time going forward until the next LTS
version comes around
so if you're working in an older project
you're probably thinking well I've got a
winforms application or a WPF
application that's running on framework
I want to update this to use net core or
the latest.net
the great part is that we can actually
do this now and we've been able to do
this since.net.net core 3.1
so you can create a WPF application and
you'd imagine that you just toggle a
switch and it just works with the latest
version but that's not really the case
you'd have to bring all your files over
and so forth but that would let you
leverage all the latest versions or the
latest language features of c-sharp
so if you have Visual Studio 2022 you'll
be able to use the latest in c-sharp 10.
and in a couple of weeks I believe.net 7
is is just around the corner and that
will also come with a new version of
c-sharp
but it'll take some time before that has
some traction because again that's not a
long time support version
to be writing libraries that Target
different types of of runtimes and you
try to use a language feature that's not
supported c-sharp 8 introduces a
language feature called default
interface methods this is only available
if you're targeting.net core 3.1 and
later so then you'll get a compiler
error
saying that well the runtime you're
currently targeting doesn't support this
feature but what's interesting here is
that we can use language features even
if the runtime is unsupported because a
lot of these language features it's just
compiler Magic
if it's capable of compiling the code to
something that an older runtime
understands you'll be totally fine and
the compiler will do its best to tell
you if you're doing something that you
shouldn't
speaking of this unsupported default
interface implementations or methods
whatever you want to call it same thing
this is something that tends to divide
people into two different groups
personally I'm not very fond of this
feature and a lot of other developers
really hate it so either you hate it or
you simply don't like it that much
so I have no clue why they decided to
add this to the language
so default interface methods imagine
that I have this interface here super
simple
I I provide this through nuget or or
GitHub or whatever this is an open
source project super popular
now I want to update this with a new
version that's generic
now I can add a method body to my
interface
which is quite odd because this means
that my interface cannot contain
implementation details can contain logic
that it shouldn't so it looks like a
class the only difference is that it
doesn't have an instance
but I can still have a lot of code here
so it could end up in a situation where
it feels like it's multiple inheritance
and a little gotcha here is that if I
have an interface that has this default
in interface method
and I try to automatically implement
this interface it's not going to
generate that method T get of t
it's just not going to tell me that it
even exists
so the tooling around this is also not
perfect
it's a bit to ask from that
so with that being said is anyone here
going to use this or have already used
it
a couple of you yes
static so
the good thing about this is for Library
developers if you have a very popular
Library out there
I understand why you would want to use
this because that means that you could
update your library and have a little
bit of a documentation that everyone
should read the documentations for every
library that you use
and then when you update that package
you have the option to override or
implement this method you won't break
anyone
because if you break people's code by
just supplying a new nuget version
people are going to get pretty upset
so I did promise that there are a few
things that are
I'm not just going to say groundbreaking
but there are things in the programming
language that architecturally change how
we look at things and it helps us drive
our development in in a direction that
makes the applications better
things like generics and asynchronous
programming and all of that that change
exactly how we interact with with
libraries in a better way nullable
reference types is one of those things
it's one of those things that in the
future we're going to be asking
ourselves why didn't we have this from
the start or or an alternative of this
from the start
you could ask yourself why did c-sharp
allow nulls from the first place
back in the day that was what every
programming language did if you design a
completely new programming language or
you start off from something and you
create kotlin or Swift you make it hard
for developers to use nulls because
they're going to end up with something
like this
if you haven't gotten this yet either
you just started development or you're
lying
because you will end up having an
all-reference exception
now nullable reference types is a way to
work around the problem it's a way to
work around the fact that we have nulls
in C sharp the best would have been to
go back in time and say hey you're not
allowed to use nulls but that would
probably have other architectural
changes and differences as well
so there's one there's a few fundamental
problems with nulls right the biggest
problem with nullability is that it
promotes that we have null checks all
over the place
it's going to clutter up the code
there's unnecessary code how about if I
know that there's never going to be a
null reference exception I always feel
like that but it blows up anyways but
let's say we're sure this is never going
to throw in exceptions it would be quite
unnecessary to clutter the code with
more null checks
and then I guess another big problem is
what does actually returning null mean
if I have a a repository
I'm asking for a user from the database
it returns null did that mean the
database operation failed did the user
not exist or was there some other
problem
so returning knowledge is a really
problem because it's ambiguous what we
mean when we do that
and it also encourages mutability that
means we can change the object if
something's null we are expecting that
this is going to be set later on which
is problematic in multi-threaded
applications
it would be better if we just couldn't
do anything everything was just read
only once you've created an instance
it's there you can't change it
in the real world that that doesn't
happen
so I tend to end up writing code like
this and I know most of you are probably
thinking well you can write this much
more pretty with all the language
features of C sharp sure enough I can
but if I can trust that this isn't the
null in this situation wouldn't it be
better if I could trust a compiler to
tell me if this was an actual or
potential problem
we can do that by indicating to the
compiler that we enable this thing
called nullable reference types
what this does is that it completely
changes how the compiler looks at
strings objects everything that's a
reference type
by default it's going to change so that
nothing should be null
it's not enforcing it there's not going
to be any problems if you set something
to know except it's going to tell you
that hey this thing here could
potentially be null
which is great this here is pretty
obvious that it's null I even I can see
that
so here it would be great to have a null
check or a null conditional operator
but of course this is a very simple
example there's much more complex
situations where the compiler can be
much smarter than I can
there's something called null State
static analysis which is really hard to
say a couple of times right after each
other this thing what it's doing is that
it's trying to track the null state of
everything
so if I pass name here into a method and
it promises that it checks for a null we
can indicate to the compiler that we've
performed in null check
and this error would have gone away
which would have been awesome
and look at an example of that student
initial Studio
now
what you can do with this here it's just
going to provide us with a warning
which is good but honestly if we have a
big project many of you can maybe work
in really large Solutions so if you go
ahead and turn this on you'll have like
a million warnings and if you're like me
like oh ignore
someone else would fix that or we'll add
a to-do
but what you can do you can treat
warnings as errors
so what I suggest you go back to work
you enable the nullable reference types
you turn on treat warnings as errors so
that every time you build there's going
to be a compiler error
you commit that into Source control and
then you leave leave work for a few days
that's going to be super popular
probably don't want to do that
so let's have a look at what this
feature actually can do and how it works
in a real application
this here is a very simple console
application I have a few classes here
there's no errors found
everything is supposed to be working
perfectly fine
I know that it doesn't so by looking at
this code here it looks fine looks like
the data classes or the the data models
that we normally write
but there are a few problems in this
application and if I enable this
language feature I could do it in two
ways
I can use a compiler directive
to enable this
which is now going to show me a few
warnings here but
I can also go into this here's project
file or do it from the project
properties and I'm going to be hurting
myself and enabling both nullable
reference types the compiler will now
look at my types as these shouldn't be
null
and then I'm also going to get compiler
errors for every time it finds a warning
now if I save that and just wait for a
little while
let me do full screen here
here we go
now we have a couple of compiler errors
right and that's totally fine in this
very small application it makes sense
it's easy for me to fix these problems
but how would we go by fixing this issue
there are a couple of different
alternatives
we can introduce a Constructor
if I introduce an empty Constructor it's
going to move that warning or error to
the Constructor because the compiler
deems that the Constructor should be in
charge of actually constructing your
object and accepting the correct
parameters
so what I can do here is I can say well
give me the first name
and then give me this ring last name
and I could initialize this and it would
all not that one first name is equal to
whatever I passed into this method
and let's do this as well now there's no
more warnings but the problem here is if
we go back to work and do this we're
going to break everyone that's using
this class they now have to pass these
parameters into the Constructor
so
another alternative
would be to um
to say that I I actually do support
these to be null for now
I don't want to ignore that they could
be null but I do want to say that I
allow you to be null
so that whoever else uses this would be
notified I can do that by adding a
question mark
and now I'm saying string can be
nullable which was the previous default
Behavior
and we'll say about this as well is that
in C sharp six and onwards this feature
is turned on by default so nothing
should be null it will complain all over
the place
Okay so
in this person class it's the same thing
it uses this details class and honestly
this isn't where the null reference
exception would occur the null reference
exception would occur somewhere else
where this here is being used
what I really want this class to be
doing is two things one when you create
an instance
I'd really like to require that you set
this to an instance we're getting ahead
of ourselves here but there's a new
keyword in C sharp 11.
called required
if you add that
to your property it would require you to
set this to an instance in the object
initializer
this doesn't require you to add a
Constructor but it kind of works around
the fact that you don't want to
introduce the Constructor
and this then can be used in conjunction
with this init keyword which is an init
only Setter it means that you're only
allowed to set this once
so after you've set this to an instance
you can't change it it will be immutable
after that
all right back to the nullable reference
types person and detail or person the
details of the person and all the
details inside of it they can all be
null and that's fine
but now we'll notice that I have a
couple of more problems
and the compiler is now smart enough
to figure out that inside this method
which accepts an innumerable of person
in a collection of people so to say I
know that this here is is going to be an
instance
because otherwise I would have to mark
this as being nullable so just
automatically checked that this wouldn't
be null notice that I got a problem here
saying that this is potentially null
that's perfect
now of course I could add a null
conditional operator
but then again I end up cluttering my
code a little bit in some places we have
to do this
but this here was actually finding a
null reference exception because if I
ran this application and hadn't set an
instance this would blow up
but let's say that I know
I know better than the compiler
let's say check for no I don't have this
method it doesn't really matter
we can do person.details let's say that
I've checked that this is null and now
therefore I know I can use an
exclamation mark it's also known as a
damage operator
because damn it I know better than you
you most of the case you don't
but it's a way for us to ignore that we
got an error
but let me get rid of that and show you
another alternative approach to this and
we'll get back to the damage operator
soon so either I could check that with
the null conditional operator or it
tracks the null State remember I said
that earlier so I could say if the
person's details
is not now
we can go ahead and do this
right
and then it just knows that I've checked
this already it knows that inside this
block it's not going to be
null at all
but it doesn't have to be in the same if
statement if we invert this
and say if it is null
it's going to continue to the next one
there we go and it just knows
so we have some options here which is
really great
we can now track down potential null
reference exceptions and this here would
have blown up but there's one more error
inside this application where it in fact
is causing a bigger issue and I know
that it's in this method here that's
telling me I should return an instance
of
something that's an innumerable of P
person
but this here is returning null
a little bit problematic
again
I can promise that I've not checked null
and the error disappeared
this is why you don't know better than
the compiler things will blow up
there's no problem doing this other than
it looks odd there's not going to be any
compiler errors it's not going to blow
up just because you do this but it's
yeah it just illustrates why it's
problematic
so instead what we want to do
we want to return an actual instance of
a person inside a list
and now I'm going to return a new
instance using yield because if I do
yield return that's going to allow me to
not have to create a temporary list it's
going to allow me to then iterate
through this innumerable and I can just
say return a new thing
this is a calling Target type new
expression and what this here is doing
this part here is actually creating a
new person
because it figures out what I want to
return here
yield return produces an enumerator
and I can say I want to create some new
details as well
It all becomes very beautiful and
sometimes hard to understand and read
and I can type here we go
right and now I've fixed all the null
reference exceptions inside this
application this was a very simple one
but at least it let me track down what
could potentially be causing some really
annoying issues in this application
this is the first thing that I see a lot
of developers turn on in solutions that
either they start from scratch or if
they go come into a new project turn it
on figure out what could be potential in
all learn the application learn the code
base
but if you're new to a project don't
turn on trade warnings as errors and
check in the code
because you won't have a project anymore
with that being said there's one more
feature so this drastically changed
actually in my opinion it changes how we
look at building our software because
now we are told by the compiler that
things could be null we don't have to
clutter with if if actually let me show
you this
like back in the day when we when I
didn't have this feature I would
Safeguard against everything right I
would do if people is equal to null then
return and if you know you get the point
right you'd have all these if statements
but if I know that
whoever tries to send null into this
method would get a compiler error or a
warning then I can trust that it's been
null checked
which is pretty cool
so it changes the way that we look at
nulls and and building applications that
uses reference types
a better alternative would of course
always be to have a default class or a
default instance of a class but that
changes the way that you think about
your applications even further
speaking of thinking differently let's
talk about asynchronous streams which is
a concept introduced also in c-sharp 8
which again if you don't know anything
about async and await this is going to
be very complex and very hard to
understand but basically let's try to
make it simple
let's say that I have this method here
I want to be able to stream data to
someone that consumes this method that
means that I can send them one item at a
time this here returns strings
and this return type indicates what type
of data will be streamed back to whoever
uses this method I can say that every
time you call this method or every time
you use this it gives you a string back
which is nice
it's marked as async because it's going
to retrieve think asynchronously
but we haven't introduced that part yet
now where all the magic happens is this
yield thing I showed you this just now
with the nullable reference types the
yield keyword has been around for a very
long time it's a way to send data back
to the for each Loop but in this case
the for each Loop is going to retrieve
each element asynchronously
so this here tells the iterator that
there's a new item to process
and in this sample here I'm going to
retrieve everything asynchronously from
the file system
this line of code here can be written
very differently and I've actually
written it a little bit differently in
in vs code which we'll see in just a
little moment
so what happens here is that it reads a
file or it starts or opens a file on
disk
using this using declaration that you
see here at the top
and then it's reading a line at a time
this means that we don't have to load
the entire file into memory we don't
have to load too much data we can skip
or stop whenever we want to
and then just to simulate some
processing I've added a task.delay
sometimes a thread.sleep or task.delay
just magically fixes problems
it really doesn't but here it's just
added to simulate that we're doing some
work maybe storing this in a database
maybe it's processing this somehow but
does that on a different thread
producing this stream of data looks very
complex but consuming it is even worse
it's even simpler
so what I do here is that I say that a
wait for each so we put this await
keyword in front of the for each Loop to
indicate that each item will be
retrieved from this stream of data
asynchronously
so what does this actually look like if
we jump over to vs code
I've got this exact same code snippet
except there's one change in here I've
changed line 12 here this line here
doesn't look
as as in my opinion this looks a little
bit more pretty but if you're totally
new to everything around pattern
matching which we're going to talk about
later so I'd be surprised if you knew
all of this already
but it's a little bit more of a fluent
way of writing the same thing
but again I'm producing a a stream of
data here I'm indicating that I want to
return strings
I'm going to start off and open a stream
to a file on my disk this is a using
declaration normally you see this as a
using statement which would look
something like this you'd add it in in
parenthesis here you'd have a curly
bracket here and you'd have one more
layer of indentation right
we've all done that but now we don't
have to do that anymore it's a little
bit more fluent
and what it's also making sure of is
that it's going to be disposed of after
this entire asynchronous processing is
completed
so then what I'm saying here is that is
that give me a line or the next line
if this is a an instance of a string
I want you to store that in a local
variable called line
if I wrote VAR here
that would actually capture nulls as
well which would make this an infinite
Loop because each time it tries to read
the next line if there's no line to read
it's going to be null
so therefore we have to be specific
about the type that I'm expecting from
this call otherwise it will not work as
expected
a bit of a task.delay then using yield
return to return this back to the
consumer
okay perfect so now we have this await
keyword in front of a for each Loop if
you've done asynchronous programming
you've probably seen that if you add the
await keyword in front of the method
call that will run that method
asynchronously right
but this here would indicate that give
me the entire chunk of data while this
here means give me each item one by one
the body will run and then it will ask
for the next element and then it will
run as for the next one and so forth
it's rather simple and rather nice
so let's run this and see if it works
hopefully it streams my favorite song
out to the console
if you don't know the song Welcome to
the internet
so with that being said I think
asynchronous streams are pretty powerful
but of course this is a very simple
example reading a file from disk getting
one line at a time
where I've used this and seen this used
in production is with things like Azure
cues you have a message bus in Azure and
you'd like to subscribe to when a
message arrives instead of having a wild
true Loop ping Azure give me the next
message you use this very concise syntax
that we have with the i async enumerable
right
there we go this one
so what this is actually then letting us
do is saying when there is a new message
in Azure give me the next one to process
and you don't have to build any long
polling yourself it will just figure
that out so the apis are really nice
like that
so before we want before we talk about
pattern matching there's a few things in
C sharp nine that's also made it easier
for us and better to work with pattern
matching that's something called records
which is a new type of reference types
I've already shown the ended only
Setters that makes properties truly read
only because you can't change them
there's a thing called top level
statements making it easier for us to
write console applications or something
known as as minimal apis there's quite a
few things
happening in c-sharp 9 as well I'm not
going to be able to go through all of
this obviously because we've only got 25
minutes left unless you want to stay
until tomorrow morning I don't have
anything planned
so with the ninth iteration of c-sharp
there's still quite a lot of things
added to the language right I think it's
pretty amazing that they're trying to
look at other programming languages
what's appealing to developers from
kotlin to Swift in Java in in many other
programming languages and take the best
of that and make it so that it feels
like a c-sharp language feature
now it's time to talk about pattern
matching
which again is one of those features
that will change how we build and write
our code the idea is that we can express
ourselves to find things in instances of
objects a little bit differently maybe
use a language that is closer to the
business
because if you show some piece of code
to a product owner like I don't know why
you would do that but if you do and they
want to understand exactly what's going
on then pattern matching in my opinion
reads much nicer than what traditional
code does
so it's a way for us to determine like
how many edges does this puzzle piece
have how does it look what kind of color
is it is the fruit edible and so forth
like we can use this until our
imagination stops there's so many things
we can do with pattern matching but
we've been able to do this before as
well for example I can check the type
and check if it has a certain color then
I would have to cast this into the
correct type before I can use that
which isn't too bad like this is some
some type of code that we've all written
and we've lived with this for a very
long time and the reason I didn't show
this with c-sharp 7 is because I
wouldn't say that the syntax or the
amount of code that we had to write was
was was less code it looks a little bit
more cluttered there's more characters
doing the same type of thing
but this here in C sharp 7 was the first
piece in getting pattern matching into
the language
we can now use a switch to look at a
type
inside the the body here
of the or inside the case here I can say
that when this is an apple I'm going to
capture that as the concrete or the
correct type I don't have to do any type
casting myself it will just work
automatically which is very nice
but in C sharp a this changed quite a
bit they introduced A New Concept called
a switch expression which looks very
different from what you might have seen
in C sharp before
so here I want to get a result based on
what an object looks like or what the
instance looks like
so this here the input is the object we
want to create different patterns for
right and then I can fill this with
expressions
to say that what type is this what kind
of properties and values does this have
what does it deconstruct to like we can
fill this with very very complex and
simple patterns
here's an example
if it's an apple just return the text
this is an Apple so just the same as
expression bodied members
after on the right hand side of this
Arrow syntax you have a return value
could have been a method call right so
this is what's returned from the pattern
this here is very powerful but this is
just checking the type and the discard
notion that we have here captures
everything it matches null it matches
not the same type you're looking for and
so forth right it matches all the things
but checking the type that's just kind
of a small piece of what pattern
matching can do
so therefore
C sharp 8 9 10 and 11 introduces quite a
lot of patterns and it can be a little
bit overwhelming as to where you would
use this
but we're going to cover a few of them
the type pattern I've shown you you
check if a type is a type there is
string right we can check if an object
can be deconstructed into an exact
constant that matches what it's
deconstructed into
so that deconstruct that we had earlier
that maybe it took the age or the
address you could use that to check
something using a pattern
more often you say property pattern but
you can also do this with tuples you can
say that given an instance of a user if
this user has not logged in for the last
30 days it should be locked out
or it should have it should ask for an
or verification through an SMS like you
could do a whole kinds of interesting
things and express yourself using
patterns
another example is you could say that a
user needs to be at least
or somewhere between 10 and 40 years old
for example or 20 and 60.
which also lets us use an or pattern
parenthesized pattern you can negate an
entire pattern say it's not null for
example
and all of these together
builds up something called a recursive
pattern you can say if it's a if it's a
successful attempt you've logged in it's
successful but you haven't logged in for
30 days then we do something that's a
recursive pattern it checks one piece at
a time
let's spend some time in Visual Studio
looking at exactly this
I've already introduced a new console
application and being good at naming I
will just call it console app2
this here introduces a concept or a few
different classes
notice that it says record this is
actually behind the scenes this is a
record class by default records are
classes they're reference types
and we get quite a bit of functionality
out of the box
before I show you how to use this with
patterns and pattern matching have a
look at this piece of code here here's a
very simple record person this here is a
d uh a a Constructor or default
Constructor primary Constructor sorry
it's required to take a name and an age
and when this is decompiled using in
this case sharp lab
the code to the uh to the right hand
side there's quite a lot of code in here
to create this reference type we have a
person that implements I equatable it
has the backing Fields there's quite a
bit of code that's introduced when we
use this new type called a record
and the reason we do this is because it
uses value-based equality so if I have
two people with the same names it would
compare the values rather than the
reference
and this also
introduces what I told you or told you
before allows you to deconstruct an
object
so why is this important because now if
I know that the record comes with
deconstruction it's value-based equality
it has all these amazing things I can
use it very nicely with pattern matching
so here I've introduced a record which
is a reference type it's a class behind
the scenes this here is called test
result the idea is that I've done a test
at University and I might have done that
quite a few times
and then it has the latest test date and
then I've introduced another deconstruct
method so with these record types which
is really reference types or classes
behind the scenes I can also have a body
for that record to introduce methods and
properties and functionality
and the reason I've introduced my own
deconstruct is because I want to also
know if this test has been archived so
when you pull this a test result apart
you can say when was this test done how
many days ago was that and is it an
archive test and those properties or
those values has nothing to do with the
parameters that I actually require on my
record
I've computed them so someone that
deconstruct this can get a little bit
more information a little bit more
detail that they can then match on
it's that powerful and a little gotcha
here is that it does generate ad
construct method with two out parameters
so therefore you cannot have two your
own you have to always have a unique
number of parameters it won't tell you
that you have but when you start using
it you'll notice
and then I have two other records either
you pass the test or you failed they
just inherit from this base record which
is really just a base class just a very
concise syntax to write new classes
it's nice for dtos and so forth but
cannot be used with Entity framework
unfortunately
with that being said let's head over to
this program file that I have over here
now I'd like to start using pattern
matching with my record type
the first thing that I'll do is that
I'll introduce a test result
I'll call this test result and we'll set
this to a default value I don't care
this can be null
if I were to access a property here down
at the bottom
it would complain that this would
potentially be null right
but I could then of course write a
pattern to test this
if the test result is null
or is not null right but I could also
say
is this test result
a a past test
let me get rid of this here
if it's a past test
I know that it's been instantiated to
one of these types I can be be certain
that there's an instance it's not null
so now if I want to use this
let's call it past
it's equal to test result as passed
but I'd really not like to do this and
as I showed you earlier with the is
string line I could do the same type of
thing here the beauty of pattern
matching is that we've already performed
a type check so how about
I say pass here instead and I get rid of
this this line that I have here and now
this is the correct type within that
scope
so all the patterns that we have we can
use them with if statements switches and
switch expressions
but the type pattern I've showed you we
can also say that if this is a path test
and I want to check the property number
of attempts
this is a property pattern and now I
want to use together with that I want to
say well if it's more than three times
you've attempted this
maybe uh
take the class again
I don't know so we can construct really
complex
patterns that allow us to write code
that we couldn't really do before
but we could all say that well if it's
if it's more or equal to one and less
than three for example
this here is now combining multiple
different patterns together
and as I mentioned we can do this with
uh the the switch Expressions so we
let's say that we want to get a string
representation of whatever this result
is we could say if the outcome is based
on the test result
we'll introduce one of these switch
expressions and I want to take exactly
this thing here
let's take that I'll get rid of the if
and then I could use this inside that
inside that block
notice how it complained if I didn't
have the underscore here
because it knows that I haven't checked
every possible way of this permutation
of this object that's why we add this
little wild call card the the underscore
the discard is the I don't care symbol
another thing here is that I could say
VAR object for example
and this here would be the same as
saying the discard it would it would
match on the same things so this here
would actually also match on a null
okay
pretty cool I think this is great but we
can also as I mentioned use the
deconstruct so where does this come into
the place I could say that well
if this this thing can be deconstructed
into something I don't care and some
variable that is less than 10 and I
don't care about the other one either
this here is super understandable
it's extremely confusing
it is
um so how do we make this less confusing
well it also supports name parameters
but in order to use that the
intellisense doesn't tell me at this
point so I'd have to say
I'd have to go into the class and copy
that over surely enough that becomes a
little bit less confusing but it's still
not the best
so in my personal opinion I'd much
rather go with the property pattern
so when is this useful
if you have a tuple if the input here
would have been a tuple let's say 10 20
and you'd have you want to create a map
for this for example say if the status
code is
is 200 okay and it had some other value
over here right
then we could write a mapping for this
which is where this becomes rather
powerful
I think that these uh these patterns and
how to use pattern matching is pretty
pretty amazing and we can combine these
as much as we'd like we could add ore
patterns we can construct more complex
things but we probably shouldn't by now
so with that being said I think patterns
in c-sharp
all of these patterns are going to make
most of our Lives easier
hopefully we'll all be able to write
code that makes more sense but if abused
it can end up not making any sense at
all
actually let me show you a case where it
doesn't make any sense
we could say
we could negate this entire expression
and now who knows what this will do
hmm
do I now care about this thing
I don't know is it more than and and
equals 210 now see this can be very
confusing so again like any language
feature you should always use them with
caution but when it comes to code like
this it becomes even more important that
you don't do the wrong things
so I mentioned that c-sharp
improves the records but we can also do
record structs that depends on where you
want your data to be stored if you want
data on the stack or the Heap you could
use either record class or record struct
if you use record struct it's not going
to be immutable by default and what I
mean about that is that if we go into
Visual Studio
and let's say that I have a record
person
it's a good example
if I can type which I can't
name and age
if I have this record here now for
Philip is equal to new person
and some age
here we go now of course I can't change
anything here
name
and this is annoying it should be name
there we go
I can't change the name after it's
created because it's immutable right
which makes sense
but for a record struct
that would be possible right so if it's
stored in the stack
it's no longer immutable so how would we
make this immutable
we make it read only
just add more keywords and it will all
be fine
if you imagine a feature is not there
it's probably there just use some other
keyword
um while we're inside Visual Studio
let's go through a few more for a few
more of these features
they also added so this here's a top
level statement it allows me to write
code inside a program.cs which is then
compiled into the traditional program.cs
it's useful because you can now mock or
test I wouldn't say Mark but you can
test features you can bring in packages
test small features out and write code
quite concisely inside this very small
class
but with that they want to make it all
more like fluent less levels of
indentation and look more like I don't
know python
look better anyways what we can do here
is that we can improve something called
file file scope namespaces so
traditionally if I want this entire
thing or all these record types to be
inside a particular namespace I'd have
to say namespace NDC and I'll have to
bring this into one of my like this here
and I'll have to indent all of this here
and it's
it's one layer of unnecessary
indentation
and if you're one of those people that
uses spaces instead of tabs
and someone else uses tabs and not
spaces this here is going to be annoying
when you check this into Source control
right so instead we put a semicolon here
and this entire file is now inside this
namespace small thing but it removes one
layer of indentation which is pretty
cool
now that I've changed this to to
namespace NDC if I go back here
and try to use my test result that's of
course not available right
because I haven't brought in that
namespace and if I change this in one
class and introduce that files file
scope namespace I'd have to go through
all my files to add all the namespaces
but they've added a fix for that so now
instead of having to do using NDC like
this here I can just say that for my
entire project
use that namespace NDC in all the types
from this namespace it's now available
through my entire class or through my
entire application
which isn't too bad I I think that's a
nice feature and you'll normally see
this in for instance
and a using.cs or or global.cs or
whatever you want to call it
um
you can store that in
in a separate file
so even with c-sharp 10 there's quite a
few features like we have the record
structs there's some other improvements
we have the global using directive file
scope namespace and they've extended the
patterns even more
so as you'll notice a pattern of c-sharp
is that they're introducing more
patterns
which is good
they're also improving Lambda
expressions and doing quite a lot of
things like allowing constants in
interpolated strings
I have a slide for that in just a second
here
but then they're allowing us to do a
whole lot of things so still C sharp 10
keeps evolving C sharp 11 is going to
evolve there's a whole range of features
that could potentially go into c-sharp
and I have some I've had some
discussions with developers that have
been working with c-sharp and other
programming languages for a long time
and it is starting to get a little bit
confusing because now we're going to
have fragmented applications people in
one Camp will use all the new features
people in another Camp will use all the
old style features
so the solution to that is just talk to
your co-workers make sure you're on the
same page introduce analyzers to analyze
your code so you code the same things or
have the same style
now constant interplated strings would
allow us to use constant values in
interpolated strings which is a nice
feature as well
but even better than this like maybe not
all of us are doing constant strings all
over the place so more useful feature is
that in C sharp 9 if you were to create
a Lambda you'd had to explicitly Define
which type of Lambda this is
which just why couldn't the compiler
just figure this out we could also turn
this around and say VAR parse is equal
to new funk of string of int and then
pass that into the Constructor but again
that's too many characters so instead
the compiler is now going to infer this
for us
nice feature nice addition and we're
going to see more of this C sharp is
going to look at your code and try to
analyze things for you it's going to
generate code that makes all of our
Lives easier because if it can infer
something maybe it can also find errors
maybe it can also let you know that
you're doing things wrong before you
know you're doing it wrong
another thing in C sharp 10 is that
they're now allowing to do attributes in
lambdas
so this here is a minimal API there's a
little bit more code to this here but if
you go in to the CLI the.net CLI and
type.net new web
you'll get something that looks like
this here
so it creates a console application that
has a few of these different method
calls where it passes an anonymous
method into it it's a Lambda and to be
able to use this fully to make it
actually useful they have to introduce
attributes on lambdas as well
so you'll see that here
so I could say that from the header
named content type map that into my type
called content type
right
so that's all C sharp 8 or even 7 all
the way up to C sharp 10. there's quite
a lot happening in c-sharp as a
programming language
so what's next
about four minutes to cover the the next
10 years of c-sharp
probably not so the reason I don't spend
much more time talking about c-sharp 11
C sharp 12 C sharp 13. even though C
sharp is going to get a new version
release in a couple of weeks from
experience it's there's going to be a
feature too that they actually remove
the day before release
so I try not to talk too much about that
before it's actually on the market but
there are a few things that I I do
believe are going to make it into the
cut
as I mentioned a pattern is to add more
patterns they're going to make it easier
for us to match on lists to say that if
this list is an instance give me the
start give me the end or give me a
portion and that will probably be used
in conjunction with a range Syntax for
example you can slice things you can use
the span patterns it's a whole range of
things that we can do
we're introducing the name of operator
they're finally going to Cache delegates
in uh cash delegates for static method
groups which is a huge performance
Improvement if you've ever run into this
issue or run into that we looked at the
required properties if I had enabled
preview features in my project and
installed.net7 I would have been able to
use that this would then require me to
always set this to a value when I
instantiate my object
they're going to change the ways that we
can write strings and they're going to
allow static members in interfaces
one more cool thing that they're going
to do is that introduce something called
utf-8 string literals so how about I
have a string here right why not just
implicitly allow me to convert that into
a span of bytes a span allows me to work
with data inside a large collection like
in this case here it would be an array
of bytes and instead of having to copy
that all over the place and have to when
I slice pieces off it I would have to
copy things this here is much more
performant and I've Rewritten a lot of
things in.net in asp.net core to
incorporate this to introduce some
performance improvements
and finally they're going to do generic
attributes
I did asp.net not core the Legacy stuff
web form stuff and then MVC and this is
something that I've wanted for a very
long time like you write on attribute
for one of your controllers there was no
way of doing it generically
so you ended up doing some some nasty
things to get around that but they're
finally going to do this
and one of the most important things
about net or and c-sharp being open
source is that everyone in here in the
community can contribute and they did
they told the compiler team that we
don't want a certain feature and they
removed it
they were going to add double bangs like
if one bang wasn't enough they're also
going to introduce this double bang
thing to say if this parameter that was
input into my method if that is null
throw an exception
and that would just happen by default
and no one liked that or at least not a
lot of people
so with that being said
there's one final thing I mentioned that
they're also going to do this static
abstract members in interfaces so why
would we do this because in this case
here if I have an interface that tells
me you need a property that is static
there's no way to enforce that but what
they're doing now is that this preview
feature
allows us to say that this is an
abstract thing and now the class has to
implement that
it's a nice addition if you do single
twins which I think a lot of us stopped
doing 10 years ago
so with that being said if you like this
I do have quite a few courses on c-sharp
on data access advanced language
features where I go through all of this
in Greater detail there's quite a lot to
to talk about in just an hour there's so
many things happening to c-sharp as a
programming language
but I hope you got a nugget or two out
of this here and that you can experiment
with record types pattern matching and
hopefully if you enable nullable
reference types and treat warnings as
errors and then just leave work please
send me a tweet
and tell me about the experience
all right I hope you like this thank you
so much I'm Philip eckberg don't forget
to vote
[Applause]